hello everyone and welcome back to match
two of the finals of the magnus carlson
uh chess tour it's hikaru nakamura
versus magnus carlson magnus this time
goes uh with the white pieces in the
first game and
uh for those of you who are just tuning
in this is the second match carl won the
first match by winning
one game with the black pieces three our
games were drawn and this is already uh
game one of the second match already an
incredibly interesting game
uh but before we check out the game i
would just like to congratulate taco
motorino for successfully saying
captures 100 000 times yesterday in his
live stream video on youtube
for those of you who want to check it
out or uh haven't seen the action live
uh
well i will put the both links in the
description below as
well it was just too big for a single uh
video for youtube to handle so uh he had
to split it into two videos but it took
him
uh well it took him a long time
many many hours to achieve this so do
check it out it's just uh well it's
something that
uh doesn't happen very often do check it
out really
yeah and an astonishing uh
accomplishment
so that being said uh let's check out
this game magnus with the white pieces
again
goes for his line uh from the game that
he lost yesterday in the match we have
knight f6
c4 e6 we have knight to f3 and d5
sorry about that uh so the queen's
gambit declined is on the board we have
knight to c3 and
d captures on c4 we have e4 and b5 so
offering this this pawn here but first
we have e5 everything the same as in uh
yesterday's video
knight d5 knight captures uh and the
knight to b6 now guarding the c4 pawn
so everything the same as in yesterday's
video however here instead of a3
which was a new move in the position a
magnus specialty now goes to a4 the move
has been
seen before although uh very few times
and here hikaru immediately goes for
queen to d7 which is a new move in the
position there are
no moves here like a6 knights the c6
bishop that
will bishop to a6 but the movie carl
plays queen to d7 is a new move
so already as of uh as of move eight we
have a completely new game already
signaling that once this knight is
kicked away
knight captures on a4 will maybe be an
idea if more pieces
join the action and you will have some
very nice development by going bishop
here you will uh
shift this bishop to this diagonal
knight c6 the e7 to d5
will be an idea in the future and so on
so here uh we have bishop to e2 by
magnus and
knights the c6 we have castles by magnus
and
knight to a5 now uh again
targeting that uh b3 square and uh
serving additional protection to c4
knight g5 by magnus now shifting the
knight over to e4
so basically inviting h6 which hikaru
goes for
knights to e4 and now bishop to b7
putting pressure on the knight but now
knight reaches uh its destination which
is the c5 square so puts pressure on the
light square bishop
of course hikaru trades the dark sport
bishop for the knight this bishop is
much too important
d captures on c5 attacking the knight
and not knights to d5
and here rook to a3 similar to the
previous game where magnus made a rook
lift with
the other rook but now this rook is also
free to roam the third rank you can go
rook f3 rook g3 if needed again go for
the g7 pawn
uh similar like magnus did in
yesterday's video so
a6 pushing the knight back knight to d4
and now comes knight to e7 opening up
this bishop's uh diagonal and the knight
will be very useful here
uh in the future it can come to f5 if
needed but also it does something very
important
which magnus seems to miss on his next
move so here
uh what you could do is rook the g3 and
roof the g3 is not only important as it
targets the g7 pawn but it also guards
the g2 form
so here magnus went queen to d2 instead
now attacks uh the knight here
and basically uh what carson was
probably expecting is something like
castles and now uh a trade of pieces
here for example captures captures
uh and then you go bishop to f3 and the
rook nicely defends the bishop
so you know you don't have a chance to
ruin a white king's side
however hikaru goes for queen to d5 here
and here we reach the position from the
thumbnail
uh hikaru is threatening checkmate and
here magnus really started to burn his
clock now
uh the thing is if you go for something
like bishop to f3 it's a very
interesting idea
but the problem is after queen captures
on c5 wins this pawn
this knight is very vulnerable here
because the rook d8 is coming so here
we we what we would see if we would go
for a forced line and
one of the reasons why magnus spent 12
minutes on this position
b4 you force black to capture alpha
c captures on b3 bishop captures on b7
knight captures and now rook captures on
b3 attacks the knight
so castle's queen side defending and
attacking twice
and here you would really have problems
because if you try to keep on defending
the knight it's very easy to pile up on
the knight
so here that white actually has a better
idea of queen e2 you give up the knight
queen captures on b4 queen captures on
a6 goes after the knight here
queen b5 defending and now rook to b5
keeps the queen back
uh queen to c6 offering a queen trait
queen a7
and now a threatening queen eight check
followed by captures here so here we
would see
any move let's say rook h38 and now it
will white will be able to win back his
p
skiing d7 captures here and let's say
captures captures and we get this
position
uh where the material on the board is
equal however uh there is the problem of
the a4 pawn it's not at all clear if
this is a weakness or a strength uh
rook t8 once it comes knight to c6 will
be
will be very tough to maybe defend it so
uh
here like we said magnus spent 12
minutes uh on ideas how to prevent mate
and in the end he played rook to g3 and
now okay the mate is defended the g7
pawn hangs
however hikaru says not a problem queen
captures on c5 i'm more
interested in exploiting this uh
weakness uh as it is
so here magnus goes for b4 he offers
this um
captures alpha for the idea of going
bishop to a3 and it's an extremely
interesting line hikaru has to capture
and now bishop to a3 offers a bishop for
a knight while also
uh the b3 pawn will be very vulnerable
so here we have queen captures on a3
queen captures on a5 and now bishop to
d5 he car defends his past pawn
next he can move the queen and maybe
even start pushing uh his pass pawn to
victory
and and here magnus after some
consideration played
rook captures on g7 but we'll get back
to that because there was a lot of talk
in the live stream
uh regarding uh the incredible rook
captures on b3
no doubt a a a move of a magician
because well it just offers up a rook
the problem is after
bishop characters and b3 uh you get
knight to b5 the queen is under attack
of course if you capture this guy gets
eliminated with
check so we would most likely see queen
captures on a
on a4 queen c5 is met with knight
characters with which just blunders the
queen
so here after knight b5 we would see
queen captures on a4
now comes knight c7 with czech king d7
and now this queen to b6 idea with
uh some very very nasty threats however
it seems that after queen c6 and
this trade of queens knight captures
here queen characters and knight
captures
uh black doesn't really have all that
much to worry about for example rook b1
attacks the bishop rogue b8 and we have
captures captures
uh and in the end we get this position
where black is up upon and it's a past a
pawn so
all in all it would be uh black who's
better but
probably not uh by all that much it's
hard hard to save this
pawn could be nursed all the way to uh
to a full point however
after this bishop to d5 move magnus went
for rook to g7
captures this pawn but now the position
is lost for him
or so they say uh and i will mention why
they say so
but first uh try to fight the winning
move for hikaru while i give you a
couple of seconds
and while i do while you do that i'm
gonna turn up some air conditioning
so uh for those of you who are able to
uh do it congratulations and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's c5
and c5 is an incredibly powerful move
because well for one it uh threatens the
well not just the threatens to capture
the knight but also if the knight moves
you you can easily get a connected pass
pawn here
uh so for example if knight f3 then you
have king of fate you push the rogue
back let's say rook g3
knight f5 everything is coming all at
once rook g4 you can play rook to g8 and
now after
after a trade or or even after h3 black
can just play b2
rule b8 is coming pawn is coming to here
or this is
this is also coming so it's not um it's
not at all clear how
how white can survive this and in fact
white can't survive this
uh so instead after the c5 move magnus
goes for
more complications bishop to h5 magnus
now sacrifices the knight
so c captures on d4 hikaru accepts and
now rook captures on f7 threatening a
lot of nasty discoveries
so king d7 hikaru runs from all of those
nasty discoveries and now bishop g4
magnus sets up more threats now the
threat is queen captures on d5
as this pawn will be pinned so the
situation on the clock is two minutes
for magnus eight minutes for hikaru and
you know
you know all hell is breaking loose here
so hikaru goes for a nice uh well a nice
king march in the style of uh
let's say tigran petrossian uh with king
to c6
now says uh what are you going to do my
queen covers the c1 square there's no
rook to c1 check how do you continue
this attack
but magnus continues happily sacrificing
pieces bishop captures on e6
hikaru captures and rook to f6 now so
the bishop is now
being threatened for capture king d7 he
could regard it with the king and now
queen b6 uh putting pressure on the
bishop here
so here bishop back to b5 he car just
moved the bishop to where it came from
and now rook to d6 with check from
magnus and now the thing
is do you go to e8 or the c8 it's a kind
of a
kind of a reflex move to go king to it
although king the c8 is much more
powerful because
we'll see why okay because if king to c8
then you don't really have a way of
continuing this attack rook the c1
doesn't work and
the idea of rook captures knight
captures and queen the c6 check
uh doesn't work because you just play
knight to c7 and the rook is defended
and
if instead of queen to c6 you you try
queen to e6 check
it's not a problem uh because uh uh once
uh this
check is completed the king will move
and now
there's no way to there's no way to
continue the attack
uh for example queen captures you're
just gonna play queen before
and uh white is down a whole rook this
spawn is coming in
this is coming so it's just game over
for white so instead of this
um instead of this idea of uh moving the
king to c8
what he covered it he moved the king to
e8 and now it's a bit different because
now this idea does have some merit so
rook captures and being five from magnus
knight captures and now queen to c6
check
connecting with the rook so now the king
has to move so king is seven
the other rook protects the this rook
now and now
queen to b7 check if you capture the
knight then we just go into the same
line queen before
the rooks are nicely connected you're
down to rook this is completely lost
so here instead of this knight captures
on d5 we have queen to c6 check
like we said uh sorry after king to e8
uh
after this king 38 move we have captures
captures and now queen to c6 check king
to e7
and queen to b7 check here magnus needs
to repeat moves to
get a three-fold repetition king e6 we
have queen to c6 check and hikaru goes
back king is seven queen b7
check king to e6 and queen to c6 check
so
magnus obviously happy with a three-fold
repetition but hikaru is not and he
plays king to f5
and here something incredible happened
the people here were starting uh to
say that uh cesa is saying that this is
a draw
and i actually checked uh ancestors
website and says they
did indeed say that this is a draw but
then after a few more moves were played
i will i was like uh
okay let's see how this is in fact the
draw uh i couldn't figure it out and
the engines don't really give any idea
as to why this is a draw so if any of
you were following census analysis or if
you have access to some incredibly
powerful engine
uh do break this down for us so we can
all you know see why this is a draw
but uh here magnus played queen captures
on the e5 and now
queen backed the e7 by hikaru so his
upper rook he just needs to play
something like rook say rugby
put the passport to victory and that's
it however e6 checked by magnus king the
g6 and now queen to e4
check king to g7 now queen catchers on
d4 with
check we have king to g8 and now queen
to g4
with chip we have queen to g7
uh and now comes uh queen to c4
so uh preparing some very nasty
discoveries with b2
and now uh that this one has reached
this far
f4 is coming so f4 hopefully trying to
get to connect the past pawns rolling
rook to b8 and now queen to e4 uh you
have to be careful because b1 pawn is uh
three probably queening queen to e4 and
now
rook to h7 uh now everything is nicely
protected the pawn cannot reach the
seventh rank
so rook to b1 magnus blocks it so he can
start pushing his pawns
and now queen to b7 offering the queen
trade of course magnus cannot accept
this queen to e2
and now rook to c7 and it was in this
position on
45 that magnus carlsen resigned the game
and again uh hikaru gets his win with
the black pieces
so he uh takes the lead in match two as
well and we'll see
what magnus can do to get back into the
match because the
improvement he found in this line seems
to have favored hikaru
not magnus himself so really interesting
stuff here we resign because there is
nothing to do you can't push
anything i mean roxy one check is coming
whatever you try let's say checking it
shape there are no more checks and once
you try
anything just roxy one check and that's
it if you don't want to lose the rook
you have to capture it
black gets another queen into the game
with check and that's that's game
so after rook to c7 magnus resigned and
what a victory
uh by hikaru nakamura so yeah
that's uh the game i do hope you enjoyed
it i would like to thank carlos harris
uh dean colettis um radim t michael
mundy and andrew hebron for contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
magnus crossing uh chess tour finals
checking up on your one of suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world and do check out the links in the
description below and congratulate
aguero motorino on his great success
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day